[Musique]
ça c'est le poste de pilotage c'est ici
qu'on peut contrôler toutes les surfaces
de contrôle comme par exemple on peut
voir le gouvernail de direction pour
faire bouger
donc c'est ici on peut voir les
déformations et les forces qui
s'appliquent sur différents systèmes
qu'on voit ici c'est vraiment la surface
supérieure de l'ale ça c'est des
porteurs de la droite
la fonction de ceux ci c'est vraiment
d'enlever un peu de portes en salle l on
peut l'utiliser soit pour tourner en
temps gage ou vraiment lorsqu'on atterri
on veut plus aucune portant sur les
ailes et rester sur le sol
ça c'est vraiment le système d
élévateurs donc la fonction principale
des élévateurs c'est de faire déplacer
de l'avion dans l'angle de tangage donc
faire pivoter la viande de cette façon
si on peut voir le déplacement c'est ici
on a des simulateurs qui viennent
exercer les forces aérodynamiques en vol
ce banc d'essai sert à tester les
systèmes intégrés de l'avion donc
s'assurer que toutes les surfaces ont
kion le système de redondance qui sont
contrôlés par du poste de pilotage
l'avantagé pour la formation en tant
qu'ingénieur c'est de pouvoir appliquer
les la théorie vue en cours dans une
machine réelle qui est utilisé en
industrie